we regularly get into difficulties in
love because we refuse to accept how
much reassurance and stroking we need
from the person we love we imagine we're
grown up we don't want to countenance
how fragile and easily wounded we might
be we don't want to see the always
susceptible and sensitive child beneath
the impressive adult
and so in the face of so-called small
things that have undeniably hurt us a
missing warm comment here a lack of
touch there we go numb instead we
silently and swiftly pull up the
drawbridge we unconsciously prepare to
recriminate We Tell ourselves that we
have a lot of work to do and should
spend more time by ourselves the last
thing we can acknowledge is that we
might be sad confused and secretly
Furious
it would help a lot if we could
recognize with grace that when it comes
to relationships we are all without a
skin we feel everything whether we
choose to register the fact or not we're
alive to every Nuance in our partner's
Behavior towards us we notice in a pain
by every piece of distance every
movement of incomprehension and every
minor slight
it is obviously profoundly tempting to
deny such exposure who wants to be
constantly reminded that they have in
effect forfeited their independence to
the moods and inclinations of a wholly
autonomous fellow human
how much more comforting to subsist
under the illusion that we might be
immune to minus lights and that our
spirits remain substantially in our own
hands
and yet it would be fairer and a good
deal cleaner to accept that once we are
in love we have no option but to feel
everything that goes on between
ourselves and a partner we have to know
on a daily even hourly basis that we
continue to matter to them it's no use
pretending to be made of rock of
attempting to be recklessly and
eventually angrily and coldly brave
we need to put in place measures to
preserve love in the face of our ongoing
vulnerability we need regularly to check
in with one another and ask have I hurt
you and then as regularly say I do still
love you it's no sign of being infantile
to approach love with immense almost
implausible sensitivity it is a sign
that we have at last accepted what a
grown-up is and needs